[Music]
miley cyrus just poked fun at pete
davidson's budding romance with kim
kardashian i thought it was a joke the
29 year old singer and the 28 year old
saturday night live star who are gearing
up to co-host nbc special miley's new
year's eve party stopped by the tonight
show starring jimmy fallon on thursday
and miley wowed the crowd with a cover
of yvonne fares it should have been me a
song about a woman who's sad to see the
love of her life marrying someone else
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah and she even dedicated the
performance to pete halfway through the
song miley walked over to jimmy's desk
took a seat and directly referenced
pete's recent romantic outings with kim
[Music]
just like miley said just last month the
comedian was spotted with the kkw beauty
founder in la driving a lamborghini suv
after a dinner date it's really lit and
fun and crazy pete has also taken the
reality star to local spots around his
hometown in staten island so make what
you will of miley's remix
[Music]
and while the singer jokes it should
have been her on those hot dates she
does have something kim doesn't a
matching tattoo with a comedian it's
pretty crazy during their chat with
jimmy miley revealed that after she was
the musical guest on snl in 2017 the two
got tats inspired by a sketch they were
both in
i'm in my terrible two so i don't care
what i do i ain't prepared for no rules
[ __ ] i ain't wearing no shoes and for
some reason we looked at each other was
like that's a great tattoo yeah we were
like we're doing this yeah and then we
did we i got uh my tattoo guy to come
and then i burned mine off and you still
have yours yeah so apparently pete got
rid of his something miley says she
didn't know until she saw a commercial
where he had several tattoos removed i'm
like wait a minute that's right where we
babies was so i am fortunate enough
but back to kim and pete yes last month
the two snapped selfies with a tourist
during a beverly hills outing they also
wore matching skims pajamas on pete's
birthday and were seen holding hands in
palm springs
and a source previously told e.t that
the two are enjoying getting to know
each other and having a lot of fun i
love that of course they first sparked
romance rumors in october after kim's
appearance hosting snl i mean i like you
just the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
neither kim nor pete have officially
confirmed their relationship and pete's
pals are staying tight-lipped too like
his snl co-star alex moffett as long as
he's having fun and he's happy that's
all i care about he's a love and his
buddy machine gun kelly gotta ask you
your boy pete davidson and kim
kardashian how happy are you for him
but we're happy yeah yeah
but et source says the two are 100
dating and having a great time together